nearly a month after the House passed
two lame articles of impeachment against
President Trump Speaker Nancy Pelosi
finally finally announced that her
urgent case needed to be slowly actually
transmitted to the Senate he abuse his
power and it obstructed a
constitutionally inspired impeachment
inquiry and in America no one is above
the law
the next step is simple the Senate
should conduct a fair trial
oh yeah he's not biased the slow roll of
policies articles that itself speaks
volumes about the absurdity of this
entire exercise when pressed about why
she decided to send the articles despite
zero concessions from McConnell on
process procedure senior members of her
own party struggled to move beyond
gibberish she's thought very carefully
about this in conjunction with with the
committee chairs who have been
responsible for this and she will you
know make her case and proceed forward
that answered the question well the
Senate Majority Leader is clearly in the
driver's seat a house Majority fueled by
political animus may have started this
with frivolity but it will fall to the
Senate to the Senate to end it with
seriousness and sobriety you bet he's
right the Senate will hold into the
lower chamber in determining trial
procedures any more so than the Senate
can dictate what the house does Pelosi
knows this though it's all it's all just
a farce from beginning to end
Mikado I frankly has been a beacon of
clarity now for weeks
raising the requirements of the
constitutional questions at every turn
he's repeatedly demonstrated how absurd
and obscene this entire Ukraine
impeachment was from the start
and today McConnell gave the appearance
kind of of holding the door open to
witnesses at the Senate trial will be
did
dealing with a witness issue at the
appropriate time into the trial and I
think it's certainly appropriate to
point out that both sides would want to
call witnesses that they wanted to hear
from a little trip going on there but as
I said last night look what Connell has
the power to end this national nightmare
he could in his opening resolution
tomorrow include a motion to dismiss the
fraudulent articles of impeachment the
facts the law and the Constitution
require it an actual trial is only
necessary if preceded by a legitimate
indictment that didn't happen here the
process of the house was infected by
partisan taint and defective legal
arguments first the house failed to make
their case under applicable law the
Constitution clearly states a person
could only be impeached for treason
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors here none of that was
established there was no underlying
crime this would be the first
impeachment in history where there would
be considerable debate and in my view
not compelling evidence of the
commission of a crime the two articles
filed against the president are
deficient on their face
the first abuse of power is just totally
made-up according to the radicals in
their party the president is abusing his
power
every time he enforces let's say
immigration law they're all saying that
all the time he can't do this he's
abusing his power so would that count to
as an article of impeachment you see how
just a wide berth this is the president
acted squarely with his article 1 powers
and his telephone conversation with the
Ukrainian president and the Ukrainian
President himself said he felt no
pressure no quid pro quo this is why the
Democrats abandon their talk of the quid
pro quo and of course all the other
stuff they were throwing in the kitchen
sink
extortion you name it there are a number
of events you are investigating to which
I cannot bring any first-hand knowledge
what I can do here for you today is tell
you what I heard from people you really
have no testimony today that ties
in Trump - a scheme to withhold aid from
Ukraine in exchange for these
investigations other than my own
presumption which is nothing that's my
favorite of all the second article
obstruction of Congress is even more
illegitimate if that's possible so now
we're going to impeach presidents in the
future who exercise their rights to
exert privileges or otherwise defend
their executive authority that's gonna
be interesting
from day one shipping company made it
clear that they wouldn't go to court to
enforce subpoenas what did that tell you
that told you they had no confidence in
their case they claimed there was no
time they pointed to the urgency of the
matter we had to stop Trump he was gonna
do it again remember all that but it was
like hurry up and wait for an entire
month tomorrow she's gonna hand the
impeachment articles to the Senate if
anyone should be charged with abuse of
power its Pelosi and Schiff if you and
Peter president if you make a high crime
and misdemeanor out of going to the
courts it is an abuse of power
it's your abuse of power you are doing
precisely what you're criticizing the
president for doing second the politics
of this impeachment stink to high heaven
always have Democrats didn't get a
single Republican to vote for it not one
the framers made it very clear that
impeachment had to be bipartisan to be
legitimate and the underlying conduct
had to be egregious Hamilton in
Federalist 65 said the greatest danger
is for impeachment to turn on how many
votes one party could have against the
other party and that's exactly what
happened it would be ideal if we had
impeachments that were neutral objective
bipartisan this case doesn't rise to
that level in any sense it shouldn't be
treated as legitimate either Democrats
used to agree that impeachment shouldn't
be driven solely by one party we are
here today because the Republicans in
the House are
paralyzed with hatred of President
Clinton and until the Republicans free
themselves of this hatred our country
will suffer history is going to question
whether or not this was just a partisan
lynching or whether or not it was
something that in fact met the standard
the very high bar back then Biden
actually remembered where he was so what
happened Donald Trump happened that's
what finally it's time that members of
Congress start earning their paychecks
we face a wide array of challenges that
need the president's undivided attention
Iran infrastructure the skyrocketing
cost of health care still this is all a
dangerous distraction and McConnell
should continue to call it out as such
oh and Mitt Romney and the other folks
who are a little wobbly maybe Mitt
Romney has the opportunity to be a hero
here yes I said hero he had a handful of
the other wavering Republican senators
have the power to preserve the
legitimacy and the check of impeachment
allowing new witnesses into the process
at this point
it only empowers the partisans that
began this madness from the beginning
the constitutional deficiency is obvious
on its face I think Romney knows that
it's imperative that they stop the
Democratic senators itching for a show
trial allowing this impeachment to go
forward only serves to set a poisonous
precedent for future commanders-in-chief
long after Trump is gone so this is the
time for the GOP to stand together just
like they did in the face of the
Kavanagh smears lending any legitimacy
to the houses acidic articles would burn
a hole through the Constitution and
frankly the Senate's legacy and that's
the angle